okay so if I we kind of got together my  producer and we thought since you aren't  done sir  we thought that if I gave you like some  names and you could create some new  dance crazes oh yeah it looks heavy it's  not I can be here okay oh you don't need  okay cool  he's like whatever used to be amazing so  he's gonna be I'm gonna call out random  things to make up a dance okay yeah no  pressure don't suck everyone's watching  okay the plunger okay do we get music or  music  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  we can just do it right here however  East End I'll try that one with maybe  fun  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  okay the Gryffindor  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  at the broom  subscribe to my channel subscribe to my  channel subscribe to my channel  subscribe to my channel please don't  make me keep going